Thank you thank you very much Tony.
My name is Paula Holden Graber as you know I'm the director of public programs here at the New
York Public
Library and I want to say that my goal is to make the Lion's Roar to make a
heavy institution dance and when successful to make it levitate
you'll also be very happy to hear that today.
We booked an event with them awesome fantastic
storytelling group in in late December in early December of
next
year and the evening will in some way be about roaring lions and
we decided that on that day it will be the last time that
I will ever say the Lions are
roaring so another that. My my
wife will be extremely happy when she hears that tonight because she's had to live with this
for ten years.
This is a Pen penultimate event of the spring live from the New York Public Library season.
I would ten Senate verse three spring season next Tuesday we end with
Vanna had a conversation about his love for ancient Greek
literature and the evening co-sponsored and Co presented by the
analysis foundation.
The event is sold out but it will be live streamed and you can
always try your luck by coming on standby.
I invited. Elizabeth Alexander because I fell in love with her
memoir the light of the world and wrote her a fan or rather a
love
letter. I have done this a few times before for instance
was adamant while upon reading that here was amber eyes and
Patti Smith just kids.
Both Edmund awhile and Patti Smith's responded positively to my letter as did.
Elizabeth Alexander and both Patti Smith and Edmund one will be back
this for. For
more it is just my hope that Elizabeth Alexander will also
come back sometime soon to the New York Public Library for
more Hilton Adams and I cooked up
a plan some years ago for a series of events that has not
yet happened. I hope there too. We will
revisit what we could do together in the years ahead.
After the conversation which will last about as long as a psychoanalytical session. If your
shrink is generous.
Elizabeth Alexander and Hilton and will sign books one ninety two books
our independent bookstore is here to help us with this sale.
I would like to say a big thank you to the Ford Foundation and particularly to their
And
Walker for their fantastic support of LIVE FROM the New York Public Library
tenth anniversary as well as the support of many great cultural institutions
across New York City.
I also want to thank our spring two thousand and fifteen season media
sponsor the Financial Times thanks to the continuing generosity
of Celeste about us and Amanda and Adam Bartos.
As many of you know for the last seven years I'm not going to retire that I've
asked my guests to give me a biography of themselves in seven
was a haiku of sorts or a few very modern treat.
Elizabeth Alexander submitted these seven words to me
mother poet
teacher race woman evolving subject to
change Hilton and submitted
these seven words reminiscent to me to the seven words
Joan Didion submitted to me some years ago the seven words she
said do not yet define me Hilton as seven.
I do not know. So cannot say he's welcome
that
Louis
Louis thank you all for
coming to
my. Song which is a little
warm and. I want to read
this.
Introduction really to you as a way of celebrating
Elizabeth and the event.
Introductions are a strange
practice but a necessary one. Usually polite at the
core fact based and essentially a centralizing.
Particularly if the host or audience
only has a cursory knowledge of the subject. But N's case none of
that's even close to the trees. I feel as though I've always known
Elizabeth or known her. And in that knowing which includes her work as
a poet a legendary professor in the L's African-American studies department.
A bestselling author and strong a committed mother of two. There
are perforce a multitude of feelings that cannot be contained in an introduction.
So the project at hand is kind of moot. As a stance Lee speaking.
But since we are
on Earth and this there is a task to
perform. Let's begin with
her birth in one thousand sixty two and Harlem USA and her
heritage which includes the people of
Harlem and her father Clifford Alexander Jr former United States
secretary an Equal Opportunity Commission and her mother the very beautiful.
Adele professing West taught legions about black women's
lives and
her brother Mark who has been a senior adviser to. And Obama. During his
first campaign and forgive me if I'm leaving something
out the point is Elizabeth a self described
race woman comes from a house not built on history lost which
is where most black Americans live but history gained. And your
ear had to be in your foot. If you didn't hear
that in her poem Praise Song for the day which she read so exceptionally
well and beautifully President Obama's two thousand and nine swearing
in and there she
said we encounter each other and where
words spiny or smooth whispered or declaimed
words to consider
reconsider and that's what tonight will give us a list with
words and some memories which might include the afternoon she read at President
Obama's first swearing and which was the swearing in of some much
more stuff too including Elizabeth national prominence
as a poet and it was the swearing in of Elizabeth the playwright author
of diva studies a play for her late husband freakery loved and it was
also the swearing in of Professor Elizabeth
Alexander author of the two irreplaceable essay
collections two thousand and four as the black
interior in two thousand severance power and possibility. Now we
have Elizabeth the memoirist the
poet working in prose and her bestselling but the light of
the world which chronicles her nearly two hundred twenty year love affair
and life with Fakhri artist and Chef father and
friend of the spectacle of the Spectacle Man who bought Black
difference into Elizabeth's black
America which is most of our America. And if you listen you
know that Elizabeth is its true laureate. Ladies and gentlemen
as myself
in
Durham
thank you thank
you I have to say the rather young man is taking
my questions.
I mean.
Thank
you so much.
With you.
Well this is something I've been wanting to do for a while
only
because you have given so much of yourself to other
people and it is a rare person who does that without complaint.
I never hear you complain only hear you reinforce and
support people and societies that you love.
That's going to be something that comes back in the conversation as a theme but I want to
start really with
words. And to talk about
your life as an artist.
Which you sometimes put to the forefront sometimes
you receive from in order to foster the talents of others but
there's no stopping you now with this book.
So let's talk a little bit about little Lizzie
M. and how does she have a she come to
be herself as an artist.
A little Lizzie
was a girl a child who dreamed at
night very vividly and who would come downstairs
to her parents and thank you for calling their names and. And say I had the most
extraordinary
dream. And if my mother who know to be elegant and dry were
here telling the story. She would say and so we would put down whatever other things we
were
doing all else would pause and you would
say what you had seen or been visited with the night before. And so
I think that I give that to my
parents who and I never knew that
other people didn't dream wildly or remember their dreams all the time
and it always surprised me featured a the most creative person I ever
knew was not someone who very often remembered his dreams.
So that's probably where it began and I think also with
listening and listening to the way that people spoke list. Listening to the different ways that
people spoke around
me listening to a Jamaican grandfather with one particular inflection one
particular vocabulary listening to and I've talked about this before my
father's great elegant Harlem
swearing that was just like nothing else thrilling. You know he would pray for
traffic so that we could hear him just you know carry on and he does
that now my children think is the most entertaining. Ever
seen and my mother's tremendously
elegant way of speaking and understatement.
And hearing
the traces of Alabama in my grandmother's speech and
seeing also the different
kinds of words that she used and would credit to her great
teacher at Dunbar High School in Washington D.C. miso to Yulia Cromwell who years
later I discovered
was one of the first I believe the fourth African-American woman to earn the Ph
D. and that she received her Ph D. in English from Yale. So I felt that
that person my my my grandmother. Correct my English and
say that is what Miss Cromwell told us. And so you know. Clearly it seemed to
me that the circle needed to be closed with beginning to research her work
and reading her
letters about her time finding her
way at Yale in the one nine hundred twenty S. and wanting to write about black people
and saying to her father but certainly I didn't come here to learn how to do
that so I will let these people teach me Shakespeare.
And I will then do what I have to do which she did in one thousand thirty one with her first anthology
of African-American writing for teachers.
So I think that you know there's all of that and also of course reading you
know also reading and I think that all of us are children who
read and read and read and read.
Yes and read everything and read what we're supposed to and read what we're not supposed
to and read ahead of ourselves. We don't read under
the desk and secret talk things you know beneath the mattress
and read. I think indiscriminately. Yes and just
put it all
in there was something extraordinary moment and
I Met Your Mother for the first time recently. And there was something something very
powerful about her presence
and one of the things that I would say was so unique
about her was that she was a woman who stood square and she looked
human and it wasn't about. Defiance or
being annoyed by your presence it was just that she was looking to see who you
were and one of the things that I love about your writing is
that you know if you go to let's get into the
individual violence but if you go through Listen to this writing the female
character whether it's Elizabeth or someone else that you're dreaming about twenty miles.
And so on they're women that look you square in
the eye. And one of the strange. I feel about Europe.
And the USA is you're looking at a street
Square and at the same time you want us to tell tell you who we are. So
I'm interested in learning a bit more about the kinds of things you were reading
that spoke to you about the kind of directness emotional connection interestingly.
That is such an interesting observation and. I think I
can you know answer it a little bit on politically because when I think about it
looking at it when I think about looking directly I think actually
about literally looking at people and looking at paintings looking
at
art growing up with art around growing up with
paintings on the wall. Many of them by my great uncle who is the painter Charles
Alston many of them which were made by my mother who was a very
very accomplished artist before she became a mother before she became a historian so
she
had many many amazing lives and so there were
always beautiful things to look at and to look at again and to regard with
care and the expectation that you would look and see something
different each time there was that kind of full on I think directness.
And
I don't know I mean all I can think of is that a certain kind of you know my as my grandmother would
say not raising that is cattle but rearing you know a kind
of expectation that as black people you
don't break. I contact with any body ever.
You know. So so that very very keen sense that the
world is yours stand squarely in it and that that was part of kind of race
work and race rhetoric and that to to break that would be
actually the
shame. This is a fascinating and wonderful segue to my next.
Because one of the things
that gets very short shrift in terms of the story of blackness.
Are the many different classes right that exist within black America and.
Daryl printing for instance is novel. Was about the black middle class and
Midwest and your family being but middle class
professionals did that in certain but worlds make you
feel side of the world. Similarly did you feel outside
of certain white world at the Sidwell Friends School
for instance because what you're really nice about friends of the of the few
similarities did. Did you feel outside
of certain. Narratives because of
that difference. Well my my
grandmother always told us she she she didn't teach us. You know
they were these kind of like people who teach you to be superior to other right. In
fact that was kind of a verboten ideology but she did teach
us that
if someone showed their racism or you know she wouldn't say show their ass.
Well you know but if they did that you were just to think of them as limited. Oh
isn't that a pity they are so very
limiting you know say you know I mean those surviving women they
were serious and cold
like that you know and then when you look for the next thing you help me with that too when I'm going
crazy you just look at me and said yes limits.
That's all you need to know and you can expend too much too much energy on it she would sometimes
she just.
You know put a finger on my on my forehead limited.
So that's the saying like don't don't use that brain on figuring this
out because you won't because racism
has infinite energy and fuel and irrationality so
don't give
it any more any. Any more power than that. And
so and that was so what I knew about the Sidwell Friends School
was that it was recently desegregated. You know so
it's conservatism which is how I experienced it it's changed a lot.
It's fundamental conservatism was something that I could think about knowing that you
know Southern senators had successfully kept black people out of it just a few
years before I got there.
You know Washington when my parents moved from New York when we moved in one thousand nine hundred eighty three was a
very southern city still in its desegregation process. And we were quite aware of
that and as New
Yorkers you know they just this was all so. So we were outside. It
was wonderful that they were from New York because we were outside of that foolishness and also
outside of a lot of the foolishness of you know black D.C. high
Bush was exactly. You know which which they taught us was
foolish. Toni Morrison when she went to Howard she said she wanted to go to a
bloody University and she was so
shocked. That stuff that you're describing in terms about this was the that there
wasn't one community it was about a hierarchy that was very shocking and weird
to Yep. And I think that so that that didn't much interest my parents and my
parents too came from different backgrounds as well so
even though
they came from. Went to the same schools came from from Harlem they came from
different Harlem's with different backgrounds. So my mother's family came to Harlem
from Tuskegee where they were a family of educators her father was Booker T.
Washington second in command his treasure when he was building Tuskegee
Institute and my father would look at these pictures of these fancy you know white
looking negroes on the porch at Tuskegee and say
well all those clothes are nice but where's the house where is the property. How could he well you
know what do you you know he was being funny but he was also sort of
saying we know that you have the educate. To show for it which obviously
he
revered but also there was an irony in there. Yes. What do you
actually have to show other than what you black people have to show for them
things to do other than being City. Other than having read a lot of books which again was
a tremendous value
but you know there. There's a kind of a practicality that he had that
I found always that that was a very interesting conversation and he would you know kind of
again embellish it Harlem story tell us they were there with your mother up on Sugar Hill. You know
and here we
were down below their
drama but I
think that the nuances and this is where you start the nuances
and the beauty and the contours and the and the and the
gorgeous differences in black when I think it's thank you keep each other and to write it
all the time. Yeah yeah. You
said I read an interview recently it was an old when we used said
that politics was chess part of the family. It was part of
the conversation. Tell me how that worked. You were brought
to today's march on Washington as a baby so.
It's been in your ear for your whole life talking about how it worked in the family.
Well what if they go to D.C. by the way. So
he went to Washington D.C. Having worked first at an organization here.
He was an assistant
district attorney in New York City after graduating law school. He served in the in the Army
as a private he worked for an organization called hard you act a Harlem
community organization and then he came at the behest of President Kennedy to
work for a moment for the National Security
Council and then when President Kennedy was killed he became one
of Lyndon Johnson's White House lawyers and one of three people
who were working in the White House Office on civil rights so he was the
liaison to the people out. Side in the civil rights movement so you know all
of those meetings that the white man set up in Selma my dad set up.
Which is just saying not to say anything about the movie but to say like a thirty one year old
black man. I start to
imagine that in the yard we have imagine.
You know was was doing that work and in a way not thinking nothing of it thinking
everything of it but stepping to the moment rising to the occasion
and always understanding that
his seemingly rarefied position was in service to what he always
on ambiguously understood as his people and our forward
movement so that was just the way people were but you know it was
also even in hearing about you know Tuskegee Yeah I mean I remember in college reading up from slavery from
the first time at the you know I
hate book he was. He still can say I got up by the
bucket but I didn't like any of that stuff but thinking about it from another
angle you know what did it mean for people born into slavery.
To be thinking in any way about the education
of newly
emancipated people. Well here's a complex an interesting point about your father was that the self
was not his old country. The Caribbean was his old country so how was
he relating
to blacks this was just blackness to him it didn't
matter geography didn't matter or what was his feeling about coming
from the west and the culture
Well yeah it's interesting so he spent all his years in Harlem but his father came from
Jamaica came to Harlem in one thousand nine hundred eighteen and my my grandmother
his mother was from North Carolina then Yonkers then Harlem and so I think part of what's
important about that is that you know global
blackness was not invented yesterday. Right right. You know
as nor was the black inland. You know no were you know I mean we've been across. Sitting
and talking
to each other and you know to quote as I always do Gwendolyn Brooks on this we are everywhere.
You know we occur everywhere and that's an old thing. So I think that part of what's really
fascinating about the history of New York City in particular and the history of Harlem in
particular is that there
was already that kind of and I don't mean to romanticize it
or flatten differences but there was an umbrella of blackness under which
many many many different kinds of people took shelter
and worked and worked
together and he I mean to give more
due to your father to give your kids that legacy is profound in
a country when most people don't know past their
grandparents what their world was let alone who their people were so when you walk into.
One of the things that I notice is that you face it squarely too.
That's a great heritage of your parents is not only their history.
But the ways in which history can reinforce our very being in the world now.
So I want to thank you.
I wanted you to read something very
beautiful because Elizabeth on top of everything else is an
amazing performer and I'm going to bust her on that in a minute but from
your book. Miss Crandall's school of young for young ladies and little misses of color which is
a great title and a great book it was published in two thousand and seven and when I think of
little Lizzie I think of the first which is called knowledge would you mind reading it.
OK And so this.
The poet Marilyn Nelson when she was. Poet Laureate of the state of
Connecticut decided that what she wanted to do the project of that poet laureate ship was going to
be to explore in poetry and turn resources to a. Boring and
creating poetry about the history of black people in Connecticut which history of black people in Connecticut.
A topic
do we know a lot about that not a whole lot.
And so she invited me she had been writing
poetry. That was delayed response like
well I'll try to make that happen a few
more things here but so she invited
me she started writing poems for young adults and she
said let's do a project together you write you know historical poems I write
historical poems. We were both obsessed with prudence Crandell a white Quaker woman who
started
school first for any young girls
in Canterbury Connecticut and then when the
townspeople there was a black girl who worked at the school
and said If I perform my chores.
May I stay in the back of the room and study with the other girls and prudence Crandall
said yes and the townspeople
objected and then she said well and they continue to object she said Well then
your girls the white girls can go home and I'll run Miss Crandell school for young ladies Little Misses of
color which she did but the townspeople so opposed
her so fought her poisoned their water source killed the
cat in tied it to the front of the you know so prevented her from
teaching
eventually set the school on fire. And so that is
her story and we thought about who was this
woman and who was this woman who met her moment who didn't set
out to be this kind of a rebel what was and who
were these young women who so desperately wanted to become educated. So.
Knowledge. It wasn't as if it
wasn't as if we knew nothing before. After all colored girls must know
many things in order to survive.
Not only could I sew buttons and hands but I could make a dress and pantaloons
from scratch. I could milk cows churn butter feed
chickens clean their coops wring their necks pluck and cook them.
I cut wood set fires and boiled water to wash the clothes and
sheets then rung them dry and I could read the
Bible evenings before the fire. My family tired from an
ending work and New England cold. They'd
close their eyes. My favorite was Song of Songs.
They most like when I read in the beginning.
And of course she's the one in it with her family the only one who can read. And so that's
what she has for them that's what she gives for
them and you know what I love about it is the humility that one
can find and try it when you're a deeply humble
person you don't have to be speak of your pride you can just
do it and that's one of the things I love about you and your word. Thank you
so I want you to read.
You know I want to read one more use Linux sequence because.
This was a poem you know one of the things about let me sing for you know.
So I'm carrying and holding this Mike because I was too vain to take off my beautiful
airings and they were quacking on the
microphone. Thank you so thank you we can do
many
things at once. So one of the things that I think
is so interesting about writing historical poems and about writing in persona is and it's a
wonderful writing trick. I don't teach. Poetry
as much as I used to but a great writing trick is to ask students to choose a
historical persona someone they're obsessed with and write in the voice of that person. And inevitably
the magic trick at the end is that you find that if you've been successful
you learn something about yourself that perhaps you might not have been able to say
directly because you're behind
metaphor because you're behind many more and the high persona. Yeah but you're writing out of obsession.
So so this is a poem called Allegiance again in the voice of
one of
these girls. And it's eighteen thirty about in these
poems and they're all
sonnets teacher is be willed or when packages and
letters come from far to say how brave how
visionary how stare down the beast is Prudence
Crandell of Canterbury. Work. She says there is
always work to do not in the name of self but in the name
the water clarity of what is right. We Crave
Radiance in this austere world light in the spiritual darkness.
Learning is the one perfect religion its path correct
narrow certain
straight at its end it blossoms and billows into
very colored polyphony the sweet infinity of true
knowledge. And so when I would start reading from
that and imagining these young girls who travelled so far and
of course you know what was travel in eight hundred thirty How did you
get from Lynchburg Virginia to Canterbury Connecticut in eight hundred thirty How did your
parents send you there how did your parents say goodbye to you. I would
think as I read and would feel more and more fervor in my body as I read that poem I would
think I believe that yes I believe
that you believe also something that is remarkable
for most writers are interested in truth in
their nihilism.
Right. Twentieth century poets have an interest in nihilism
that the world begins and ends with their words one of the things
that's continually continuous Is that your work is a continual
one gesture poetic is to me leading
into the prose gesture or dramatic gesture and I'm
wondering about the power of different genres
for you when you're writing decision would dictate or do
you dictate how you are going to
say well I've had a very very interesting test of that with this memoir with the light of
the world and since it's a
memoir and I am more known for writing poetry I've just been on this book tour
and people ask me what have you what else what are you working on now you
know they like.
Please please know what. Like I said right now I think I'm working on right now.
Oh yeah that's right.
I mean it's a reasonable question but you know but also you know that
the sort of you know arguments and are
you writing this are you writing the statistics actually back to
me
but you know are you writing poems do you still write. Do you still write poems
and so to a few of my poet friends I've sort of you know dramatically taken to the fainting couch
and said I will never write poems I no longer write poems.
You know never
again and that you know that is dramatic but what is true is
that writing this book showed me very very keenly
that sometimes you know though I
as a professor and a scholar I'm incredibly interested in general I'm interested
in wrote a whole dissertation on collage in Highbridge honor as you know black women's creativity.
I think that the properties of genres are very very marginal are very
very important I think that that young. Writers need to
understand
what they are writing in to and against both historically and
also formally these is very very very important but right now what I'm
feeling is that to police those borders to avidly is
sometimes fundamentally anti creative. Yes and that you
know
if to discover that I can feel a
word and then a phrase and then some music coming up out of my visceral in
the way that it does in poetry but that then builds into something that
is prose but its own kind of prose is is absent.
Was
thrilling and it made me feel that I
could make so much more it made me feel that I could keep working.
It made me feel that I was a real artist more than I ever felt that in my whole life.
So I feel that I have to honor the fact that John Roe
was broken.
Yes you know because it made something
else for your role as broken right. Your
persona
was cracked. Yes in the most essential. Way it's like a
vase and something cracks and things still keep growing out of the.
That's right right that's beautiful that's exactly right thank you yes and so one of the
things that one of the things that I think is I'm just going when I was
preparing today. I was going back in my mind
to amazing moments watching you we stand up
for poetry now when you started the Poetry Center at Smith College this is your
first
job Smith I know my first so my first job was at the University of Chicago Chicago
my first first job was a year at Haverford College and then Assistant Professor ship at
the university. And then to mess with them
and and then Smith was after that after I ran away and joined the circus
and fell in love and started having babies. I left Chicago and was
the Conkling poet in residence and you were a Conklin writer there as
well and and the the amazing Ruth Simmons was the president
at the time and she
had said to the entire campus and by the way she very pointedly said and to the
entire campus I mean the people who were cooking in the kitchens. I mean the
professors I mean the administrators I mean the sound people who you know make our
guests voices audible. I mean everybody. What are your dreams for this
campus dream your dreams and write them and send them to me and we'll see what we can
do and that's how the engineering program was born it's mis read an
extraordinary one and that's how the Poetry Center was born as it happened. The moment that
I arrived there. That was blossoming and they said to me would you want to run
this Poetry Center.
Well here's a song about that we both enjoyed our time immensely and one
of the things that was very hard to do walking down Queen Street
was not to tear up when I saw the engineering building
because he says girls can't do math right that's right and
I often wanted my classes to be in the engineering building just inspired.
The fact the architecture of language was my whole point. But
anyway
so
one of the things that was powerful to me when I was going to the Poetry Center was to think
about the ways in which your family
activism you had translated that to the academics.
Making them to yell so powerful and huge when you were
running at starting the Poetry Center it's a mess. I D's.
I want to call them. Sort of righteous activities. Is this part of
your D.N.A. as well.
Well it's interesting you know I've been thinking about all of those kinds of things even at Haverford. You know
always you know some of it
is always willing to put on a show and loving putting on a show
and being really bossy. And you know really and just
loving extravaganza and loving getting everyone excited and going to the barn and you saying let's
go let's know come on this is great but also I've realized. Seriously
I swear to
God It is about redistributing wealth and getting into artists and people of color and women.
And that is a through line all the way even from in college.
I would find what little money was there and turn it to you know ritual of descent
this incredible Journal that some of us made of African-American Arts and Letters.
I'm always finding the money asking the money hand in hand raising the money
and making something happen that wasn't supposed to happen in that space.
You know but that needed to happen in that space. Or that needed to happen more fulsomely in that
space making sure always that artists were paid and paid properly.
I mean you know to the best of my ability. It seems like a little thing but it's but having
done it now
for thirty years. It's very very important. I work at
a zillion Arish University. You know if there's so much
money black folks and colored folks and women and
poets ought to have some of that money because we're dead without the work they don't there's
nothing without that you know we were when you were big if you know that's
right that's right and I mean also as a friend of mine says about getting paid she said next
time you're not getting paid just look out and the person who made the ice sculpture
got paid. That's right you know. And right in the person who's pouring the drinks
is getting
paid you know everybody's getting paid so. So the artists need to get paid
and institutions I think that have resources. I think it
is a joy when those resources come to flow in the survey.
The life force of
our energy visible evidence. This is capital so they want to see what's going
to happen. If they give you that twenty five dollars What can you do with it. Here's
another seventy because you did this.
Let me know how to do. Hello.
So here's my statement was that when you did a reading.
It's a two
pronged question stating that Helen Vendler wrote an essay
about and psychology of poetry
that came under a lot of discussion let's say because she was saying that there
was not really enough black poetry to make an anthology that's one of
her criticisms that second part of that
was when I saw you in the waiting
room. And there was you were there but you didn't feel the
same way that this Elizabeth felt about looking at these black women National Geographic was
one of the
profound performances where was that was that Smith No no you were doing it
with frankly doing a bunch of other people dream and. I was at a.
Yes yes yes
and I was there. And it was one of the greatest performances I've ever
seen and so I wanted to talk about this idea of
the black from that. In poetry.
And also a little bit of the ship and I'd like to talk to you about it.
Yes I love Elizabeth Bishop. She's she's one of my favorite
poets and I think one of the interesting thing about living with certain
poems over time and revisiting them and going back and
understanding or being interested in different things as
as your own life changes is that great poetry will continue to
reveal those different things to you and allow you to have. Like I have a real
relationship with this poem. Because when I first. Read it my
grandmother who didn't didn't she didn't read it a lot of modern
poetry but she had a copy of Elizabeth the ship's Geography three. That
was one of em when I She had a beautiful little perfect bookshelf and her little beautiful
tiny studio apartment near the United Nations and when I would go and visit her which I did
often I would read her books over and over again and this Elizabeth Bishop was one of the books she had I'm not quite
sure why you know she had counted CULLEN You know shit classic
black poetry. She had Shakespeare but you have this Elizabeth Bishop and so the part that
you mention I remember as a child
being
compelled and a little embarrassed and fascinated and not
having words for what I was feeling and then different points revisiting the poem I had
more words and I think also maybe it's important to talk
about the part of an artist that is. She your ego.
You know of of just following language that overrides all language you've ever made
before and about reading other poems and wanting
to say those words as though you wrote them to take them in your body that way
and so the sheer ego part of me
loved reading a line that you'll know when I come to it you know. So in the
right in the waiting room.
It's given room for.
OK. Yeah
OK in western Massachusetts.
I went with with Aunt Constance hello to keep her dentist
appointment and sat and waited for her in the dentist's waiting room. It was winter
it got dark early the waiting room was full of grown up people arctics
and overcoats lamps and magazines.
My aunt was inside what seemed like a long time and while I waited I read the
National Geographic I could read and carefully studied the
photographs the inside of. Volcano black and full of ashes.
Then it was spilling over in reveal it's a
fire OSA and Martin Johnson dressed in riding
breeches laced boot boots and his
helmets a dead man slung on a pole Long Pig The
caption said babies with pointed heads well and round and round with
string black naked women with necks wound round and round
with wire like the necks of
lightbulbs their breasts were horrifying. I read it right straight
through I was too shy to stop and then I looked at the
cover the yellow margins the
date suddenly from inside came and. Of pain on
console way Loz voice not very loud or long I wasn't at all
surprised even then I knew she was a foolish timid
woman I might have been embarrassed but wasn't what took me completely by
surprise was that it
was me my voice in my
mouth without thinking at all I we
were falling
falling our eyes glued to the cover of the National Geographic
February one thousand nine hundred
eighteen I said to myself three days and you'll be seven years
old I was saying to stop the sensation of falling off
the round turning world in cold
blue black space but I felt you are and
I you are and Elizabeth you are one of them.
Why should you be one too and the poem goes on from there.
So you know just sort of you know what to make of of
of her Harrer is that a racialized horror. You know we get the word black before we
come to the black people. The black in the volcano and you know something's about to
happen and then
her horror at these images in. Geographic But is it a racialized
car is it the kind of voyeuristic horror of
a
child who can't turn away and trying to sort of think
about that. And the satisfaction even as a young girl even in
that discomfort which
I knew there was something that wasn't quite right of being able to then speak the
line and to see it in a poem I know meant something
to me.
There is something
very tender and with that in your book poem
possibility which I hope you take up it's a wonderful book. And the
first one is
about a poet that mattered a
great deal to me as a young person poem and stunned.
And I used to try
to dress like parliaments and read to my mother
as if I'd written the Proms. And it was another love Paul line.
And
so I want to this is this is a wonderful occasion
to read the first couple of paragraphs from Elizabeth's essay
called Dunbar lives which if
you know anything about you is a reference to bird lives in
the course of writing this essay I found something that surprised.
Dunbar and that is for a much to contemporary African-American poet and I've also discovered
have done by matters to me several years ago in conversation with
another African-American poet.
I mentioned that when I was growing up my father would occasionally recite parliament says
Dunbar's the party. He did so joyfully and apropos of nothing but exuberance as
far as my brother and I could
tell this was always a thrill. He had slipped into the
vernacular as we
said for now if you are always having the articles. And once movements from another
time the speech just said.
I was describing described as. Slipping. I think actually that noticing
and leveling the shifts and direction.
What made me a poet growing up around my mother Sugar Hill Harlem Queen's
English my grandfather's Jamaican music and vocabulary use a figurative language.
My grandmother saw strong that Alabama flowers
mix was was a chance to turn synthetic starch shaped by
her teachers and one hundred twenty S. parlance Laurence Dunbar High School in
Washington D.C. Now this is something that you come to again and again
especially in your discussions further with Sterling Brown and Gwendolyn Brooks and it's
just it's just really this sort of amazing amalgamation
of different sounds that come out through the sensibility of you
or sterling or whomever but one of the things
that interested me in terms of your development
was when was it clear to you that's a music was something that
was feeding you as well
because we certainly enlistments read very
brilliantly at the Village Vanguard you with your Stravinsky.
And and I'm wondering was it because you were a dancer.
First I think that.
You know I always just took music sort of for granted. I mean it was it was ambient
my parents had records my parents had dance parties that was love when they had dance parties
and my brother and I would watch and see what was going on from
behind closed doors and that was another kind of slip. You know like these
very you know pulled together. You know race people by
day and then you know just getting down by night. You loved watching that
that transformation. I still love I love those moments you know like oh well
there she got it right there.
She put it away.
But I think that's a very of there a very beautiful and mighty kind of a.
Oppressive power. Yeah and you know how I mean the great traditions of
black music right I mean
how you know from jazz there was a I've talked about this great D.J. and Washington
named Felix Grant who had a show and of email and that began at nine
o'clock every night I would listen to when I was doing my homework on my little transistor
radio and it was a very
kind of old fashioned wonderful educational jazz show you know
not quite like the Leonard Bernstein Peter in the wool for the you know the concerts for young people it
wasn't that kind of Dinosauria not didactic but I learned so
much listening to that there was always there was always
music that was where my first little bit of money would go you know when there were the you know fifty
Cent record been forty and they have a little hole punch in the corner and you could.
You could you could buy them so music was just very very important and I think that certainly yes you
know growing
up studying dance very seriously being very devoted to
that I think that that was classical music which
I
don't really know except through dance but I think the understanding
that you're trying to make your body move
in relationship to this music and that music gives you structure and form
is certainly something that came forward into the making of poems.
When you were in college and going through college and grad school and.
One point in your budget for you worked as a newspaper person but it didn't
speak journalism didn't speak to you as a writer he said defensively.
Why don't you tell us why. And it wasn't that it spoke to me greatly as a
writer I and I love. Journalists and their mission their
knowledge and their service to the ranger she's back
there
anything that's I mean I really did I I love I love journalists and when I.
Little
period working as a journalist I felt that it made me much braver you know it gave me
a reason to go talk to people that I didn't know and to explore the city where I grew up but
to places where I hadn't been because they'd send me to you know Lorton reformatory to write a story about something
that was happening there they'd send me to you know wherever I
went I went and I had a reason to be there and so I couldn't be shy
and that was a really really great thing but what I realized was that it mean it's really true
I felt the will to
embellish I felt that I could see the line and this is very serious business
because it was The Washington Post sure I arrived shortly after Janet Cooke
unceremoniously left and this is an amazing story of a black woman
journalist who made up a whole story about you know. Eight year old who was on that arrow and so
forth and it turned out and this. I don't know maybe I need to write about that one day because this is
still one of the most stomach churning dramatic tales of an aggressive today I have
ever
heard of you know right up to you know the say resume and when the story falls apart
then on her resume it says that she speaks French and then Bradley comes up to her in the newsroom and says.
But if it's a bunch of it's also. And she can't answer because she doesn't speak French but she's
put it on her resume that she does like
this part in the NEWSROOM he unravels her but she's unraveled herself.
Lord have mercy.
So let's call that So in the space of that's right and you know. And
also that all
the black editors and reporters at the newspaper always knew she was
lying yes. And they told the white
people or they didn't tell the white people because they didn't want to bust her it's
right because they knew that the story made no sense that's right. And they knew that
the corner she described did not exist. That's right.
So then the story also on Ravel says you know the editors say OK take us
there and she can't.
So I digress but it's just to say that. That was the climate. You
know mendacious black women you know who was was sort
of in the air and when I started feeling that there
were you know like here's what was
true but I was interested in what was kind of right over here. That that
actually did tell me that I wanted to be a different kind of writer but I feel so
grateful even just for a journalist relationship to time you go from journalism to the Academy
where nothing's ever really do and shame is the motivator because you
said as opposed to like you don't get in by five and you're not in the paper and maybe you don't have a job a next
day I love I love that I think that's just a wonderful
thing and sometimes I pretend it's true. Yes I need to get things done but you'll
be fired. What are
the one of the things that I loved about your relationship to
the stories over there
was a selling feature of your play
writing and it's something that I've always been pushing you to go back
to but it was one of the things that
feel so in love with. So let's talk about
that aspect of your life as a
lover and how that says a word and also what that life
is yes well you know I love Look where we are
OK
yeah. And but more importantly it's not just the Africa and then we're about to talk about
my late and beautiful Eritrean
husband but I mean that's how he painted our children. You know like little Perseus like
yeah beautiful to see just like just like that with very knowing faces.
But with kind of east African Coptic iconography in the eyes and so
forth so I feel that we're actually kind of in exactly the right space yeah.
So you know the
discovery and a disco around that was me not.
Skipped over the
disco. But you know what can I say I mean I was
lucky enough to have a partner who believed in me as no one ever has or will
you know and who loved that I mean as I wrote in the light
of the world.
I love that she was an artist I love she was a teacher I love that she had short hair. And
that we instantly went on with it and made our life together after
one week after you know he saw my play his first words to me which
are you know they're it's funny now when again you know we seem to have this theme
of you know the kind
of you know he's like oh I loved your play. Could we talk about it
why
certainly my
work when I sit down and I'll sleep with
you but then I never left so it was
OK OK That's OK.
But you know but but to just just to say to say
yes to well my situation. It wasn't a situation. Oh no
it wasn't that I don't again I was in that kind Exactly and it was rationed. But you know
to to be fortunate enough to find. A soulmate and again
I think the important thing to young people in the room is is that
really seriously is the saying yes. You
know seriously that's very
emotional. Yeah. And just saying like I'm going to do this I'm going to do
this I'm going to leave my job. I'm going to let this person come
and pick me up in
the car and take me halfway across the country and I'm a start having babies and he will
not let me star and I will get a
job because that's how I made and that's how I was raised and we will be
fine and we were.
And the power in the beauty was that you know to each other
he you know an amazing brilliant person who came as a refugee
from Eritrea first walked out of the country it's. Sixteen to
Sudan went to Italy went to Germany landed in the United States worked as an
activist then worked in a million kitchens been made a restaurant with his
brothers for sixteen years then really devoted himself to painting that devoting himself
to painting he had always painted but I was the one who
said really let's do this really let's do this
and
now to get to be to be artist together.
Well you know but to him to say like I see it but it was it was collective because you know we had
to we had to make conditions for each of us to make our work. So if
that men were you know finding a
place where he could you know turn the garage in the back into a studio or if that meant
you know that he would take the kids on an adventure while I would get my writing
done or that we would take the time as we did to always be
each other's usually only critic he was my only the only person whom I ever showed
my work never ever ever ever. And he would always tell me what he thought
very very honestly as I did with every single line he ever made so
that kind of one
of the things that is so brilliant really describes the many
languages of languages he spoke so it was almost as if you had a built in
translator for what you were working through as an artist that was someone who could hear
languages that maybe weren't even on the page you know and that's so
interesting that's what I thought when I read we read the book I said Triqui was an
amazing translator as well translator of your poetic soul.
That's really amazing because you know he so he had a gift for languages
but I mean it wasn't it was also forged out of necessity through
brutal colonial occupation and relocation. He didn't just say you know you
must get to speak English well that's exactly right you know he didn't you
know aspire
to study German he learned German because. As he ended up
there and had to figure out a way to go to school he didn't know word. And
in nine
months he was successfully going to school in German you know having his
and that's just one of the many you know these are languages that aren't even like each other German
is not like. Arabic is not like it's not like Spanish is not
like you know Italian I mean there are relationships but but but so
so he was a gifted child but also history demanded these things of him
to survive. You know and the bounty of that you know once he was
safe and once we were in one place and building a life together was
indeed someone
who knew so many things and had so many words and so
many sounds and we would we would talk about what were the things that
we had we had so much in common even though our lives were seemingly very different and
started halfway around the world and we would talk about it was interesting we discovered we.
Growing up and the book talks about this a lot.
How do people born halfway around the world find their way to each other and make a life together. Well
it happens every day it actually happens every day.
Well I have only one slight objection to
what you said and it's only because I
feel so
much love for you just reading
everything and the person that emerges is someone
who
was perfectly true but had yet to hear the
notes of the person and so when he spoke in your book
you talk
about your body really I don't think that that's just for young people. I think
that when we stay open to the possibility of love and
connection that weird relaxation happens to us.
Wow And so you know I feel like talking to you.
It doesn't it doesn't it doesn't mean
anything in terms of the being part of what makes
the next level accessible. I think it has everything to do
with what we do where we put our bodies in the line of fire and
you put your body there and he did too and one of the
beautiful parts of this is the
relentless drive and you let him drive the car.
Everyone has to have one person in this life. The absolute truth.
When they say you know I was at work and I told this film and I didn't
do you know that
person but I didn't call
my mother back and she and I said I left a message and I didn't do that all of the
stuff that makes us feel morally compromised.
You have to have one person. That you feel that you will go crazy.
And so the power of the book. Is that you're
not just telling. That in life that you were sharing but
you're telling it and so do. And so doing that you're telling it to the rest
of thank you you know I mean you
know that's thank you and I think I
don't think you will ever stop having that it's.
Well you know one of the things that's been really interesting and
I say interesting because you know with books of poems people meet
the poems in all kinds of ways for all kinds of really interesting
reason but there are a lot of people who come to this particular book because it's
memoir because of the story. But it's not just because they feel like
that happened. It's
because something else happened to them that feels resonant. And that
they want to share and so that's been really interesting but but I've also
been learning this is to your point
about. Kind of what happened to make
this book.
You know and I've been thinking about you know you cite the passage where.
I describe myself as a backseat driver and you know. There's so many revelations.
But then I finally relax and then you know recall at
the end of that I open. I open my eyes and I hear his
voice and he says and this is after we've known each other for a month he said
Lizzie calls me Lizzie has never called me Lizzy before. And
he says and that's my intimate name from my niece and nephews. He says
Lizzie you have land in Africa. And I feel
like I
just for witness to some things in this book
and you know because organ when I describe you know going with when
my son Simon at the age of twelve says Do you want to come to visit Daddy with me
in heaven. Yes you know and I'll take you there.
I feel like I mean yes you know craft.
Absolutely there's a tremendous tremendous you know blood soaked sweat stained
craft in here and I'm very proud of that but I also feel like there's a bearing witness
to life and its power and its beauty and its terror we were
talking earlier about you know there's the real quote in the book that so meaningful to me let everything happen
to you Beauty and Terror and then it continues no feeling is final.
And so I feel that that's kind of what happened here.
Exactly it's sort of like when you're watching a film and you're looking at
the corners of the film and you know that there's
life being framed. But it's there
and that's pretty permeating and making the image so this is.
It's not just. You see but what's around and aura of the
and or of your writings. Has something to do
with lace that will continue past the age.
A lot of what I meant by nihilism the poetry twentieth century poetry was that the world
begins and ends with it and a lot of twentieth century and twenty first century.
It's one of the things and poetry encompasses all of your work.
One of the things that is extraordinary about all of your
work is that it continues past the page in
my mind you can go. You can visit to
take your writing and then your mind will go somewhere else
because that was the passport to go somewhere else.
And that I think the one of the pleasure you know I mean of
course writing it is not pleasurable and profoundly pleasurable. You know I
mean actually doing it it's so hard isn't even the word what is the word for
what we what
we do when we labor to make
it but then something similar
but then when you turn the corner there's no ideal and. There's no
better feeling when you can make
shape from all the muck and that to me that that the
joy of the experience of kind of following you talk about the passport.
You know following this to this to this read a little bit.
Well I'm just desperate to have you do that and I just wanna say one other thing to
that point was that one of the things that I love about the book and
all of you writing I really want to stress people. You've got to read the whole
schmear there's a great Marshall essay called The poets in the
kitchen and she talks about the West Indian women sitting around the table
and discussing life. And what you were talking about past
the aspect of it really is the voice of the
book. To be
a literary convention.
And it's free in that way that conversation and the soul is free to me
is really. Wow Did you
have you know what I love they would like to part of just
a list of the things that you have to do over you know when that's from children.
Yes yes. Is that is that a good
thing that is good. OK. Yes
please
take but I mean.
If
you
don't that's OK so we would have loved you
know we had fifteen Christmases
together almost fifteen years of marriage sixteen
years together one thousand nine hundred six to two thousand and twelve we always said it felt longer than it
was I would estimate at the end that we had a twenty five year marriage and secret I
would agree
that long that much struggle that much do you believe in
our extended family and family or friends two cancers two heart surgeries one
drug addiction two mental hospitalized patients marriages babies
funerals Easters and
Thanksgivings our friends' parents and one friend's son died together we went bearing
food and hot coffee together we went to the various places of worship in our best
black clothes three houses two cities one job change two closed
businesses one started business money went money
came several bad boy. Friends of nieces several good three
lovely husbands of nieces one lovely wife of a nephew six lovely
babies four homes. Owned three sold hemorrhoid surgery dental surgery.
No broken limbs one political regime change the end of one war the start
of another an East African American
US president several refugees to US naturalization
swearings in two new
citizenships together we chose to daycares two nannies fired one nanny in six
days because it one and a half Solo said
no stayed with the other for three years and wept when it was time for her to leave
us one nursery school two elementary schools one middle school one high school
we planned fifteen Thanksgiving dinners fifteen Easters and at last one
feast of the seven
fishes one Easter faecal I found a sheep farmer in Cheshire Connecticut and had
a lamb slaughtered for his sister to do for her said hey they're rich and spicy
Eritrean meat stew and her roast we found where we could buy Italian Easter
bread shaped in across with a hard boiled egg baked in one pass quite he'd say and so would
I three trips to Italy where we had family in which was our
ironic colonial Demi motherland. Each time to different places Rome
Venice Florence a mouthy yes but also body. Julia set out to see in-laws
and friends London Scotland Spain Oakland the diaspora of our
family Milan awaited and bellicose Ghana and Naples. Once the crime
settled down and Cecilia he wanted to smell the mint crushed
underfoot the Alhambra awaited and the orange blossoms in southern
Spain in very early spring
time.
And then.
We loved Jimmy Scott's version of The David Byrne song have. And heaven
is a place where nothing ever
happens these days I picture heaven populated by the ember and
jewels faecal I painted in abundance but that seems too fanciful
I never truly believed in heaven and cannot manufacture it Little Jimmy Scott's
plaintiveness seems right when he sings nothing ever
happens how better to describe the infinite solitude of the afterlife.
When this kiss is over it will start again it will not be any different it will be exactly the
same he sings each kiss is fixed it is the same long kiss but
it will never change that is the comfort and that is the heart
break one night at bedtime Simon asks if I want to come with him
to visit seek a day in heaven. Yes I say and lie down on his bed.
First you close your eyes he says and ride the clear glass
elevator up we go. What do you see I
ask God is sitting at the gates he answers.
What does God look like I ask like God. Mommy. He
says. Now we go to where daddy is he has
two rooms. Simon says one room with a single bed and his books and another where he
paints the painting room is vast he can look out any window he wants and
paint that room has four views our backyard. The doc you painted in
Maine as Mara and New Mexico New Mexico.
I ask. Yes Simon says the volcano crater with the magic grass.
I guess I say the call data where we saw the gophers and the jack rabbits
and the elk running across and daddy called it the
veldt Yes. Do you see it and I do see
it the light is perfect for painting his bed in
Heaven is a sea. Engel bed.
OK it's time to go now Simon says so down we go. You can come with
me anytime he says Thank you my darling I don't think you
can find it by yourself yet he says but one day you will.
Thank you
Lou Lou.
Really. I think
you.